The slow-burn monstrous horror of Midnight
Mass and its chilling story of angels, demons,
guilt and redemption, leads to an explosive
ending that will leave you thinking about
the show long after it's finished.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything about
the ending of Midnight Mass, some crucial
details you might have missed, and why that
final scene doesn't quite mean what you think
it does.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
To fully understand the fiery finale, we need
to go back to the origin of the miracles and
mysteries that occur on Crockett Island after
Father Paul arrives.
Paul, as we discover in the third episode,
is actually the island's original priest,
the elderly Monsignor John Pruitt who's been
transformed into his younger self after a
pilgrimage to Jerusalem.
During his trip, one day Pruitt was separated
from his group and ended up outside the city,
wandering on the road to Damascus.
As a sandstorm hit, he sought shelter in a
cave where he was attacked by a winged vampire
who bit his neck and began to consume his
blood.
Before the priest died though, the creature
pierced its own skin and fed his blood to
Pruitt.
This is my blood..
..shed for you and for all so that sins may
be forgiven.
These words are from The Last Supper and are
a crucial part of the Catholic Mass and doctrine
which states that the bread and wine offered
during communion become the actual body and
blood of Christ.
By saying this about Pruitt receiving the
creature's blood, Paul shows that he believes
it's a holy sacrament equivalent to the blood
of Christ.
Pruitt believed it was an angel – notice
the Halo which he sees form around its head.
Paul calls the wound the creature makes on
its wrist a stigmata, referencing the wounds
inflicted on Jesus when he was crucified.
Also notice that the wood carvings illustrating
Pruitt's experience are numbered from 1 to
14 in Roman numerals, a nod to the Stations
of the Cross, images often found in churches
which depict the events of Jesus's crucifixion
and death.
When Pruitt awakened he decided to take the
name Paul, in reference to Saul who became
Paul when he experienced a life-changing event
on the road from Jerusalem to Damascus that
converted him to one of Christianity's most
renowned apostles.
Similar to Saul, Father Paul believes it's
his duty to spread the miracle of what happened
to him to the whole world and he begins by
smuggling the vampire back to Crockett Island
in a trunk.
On the island, Paul begins to add the creature's
blood to the communion wine, and little by
little those who take communion find their
physical ailments slipping away.
Riley's mother no longer needs glasses and
his father's back gets better.
Even more miraculously, the paralysed Leeza
finds she can now walk, while Sarah Gunning's
mother Mildred regains her mental faculties
and begins to de-age incredibly.
After a while on the island, Paul starts to
feel sick, then suddenly keels over and dies.
A few minutes later, he comes back to life;
however, he now discovers that sunlight burns
his skin.
He's also no longer interested in regular
food, his body instead craving human blood,
which leads to Joe Collie's death and and
Paul's next bloody meal.
Later, Paul discusses with Riley whether he
felt any remorse for his part in Joe's death
and justifies his lack of guilt by quoting
something Beverley showed him in the Bible.
The graces of the Holy Spirit rained down
on me..
..cleansed my conscience, for I had simply
done His will.
The priest's appeal to the Bible as justification
for his actions shows how misguided he's become
and is a warning about those who use religion
as a reason to justify terrible behaviour
and atrocities.
By contrast, Riley demonstrates the ability
to avoid giving in to temptation when he goes
out on the boat with Erin.
Riley's resistance here matches his own struggle
with alcohol addiction and how he genuinely
felt culpable and remorseful and took responsibility
for the death of the girl he killed in the
car accident.
You struggled..
..with what happened
With what I did.
Paul however twists his religion to suit his
own purposes while making out that he's somehow
doing God's will;
and together with the wickedly holier-than-thou
Beverley Keane, puts into action a terrible
final plan for the Easter Vigil.
At the Midnight Mass, Beverley distributes
cups with a lethal poison while Paul urges
everyone to drink so they can die and be reborn.
Let your earthly body die, so that your divine
body can awaken.
Anyone who's already taken communion since
Paul's arrival on the island will have drunk
some of the Angel's blood and so they will
resurrect soon after dying.
In the chaotic events that follow, the reborn
vampires attack any still-living humans as
they try to flee the church.
The events of the vigil bring to mind the
real-world Jonestown Massacre in 1978 when
members of the Peoples Temple cult committed
mass suicide after their leader Jim Jones
exhorted everyone to drink a poison-laced
Kool-Aid-like drink.
The bloodbath at the church spills out onto
the rest of the island with Bev encouraging
the new-born vampires to kill or convert anyone
left.
She orders every building to be burned so
there'll be no refuge come sunrise except
for the church and rec centre, and she sets
herself up as the moral arbiter of who's worthy
to be allowed in and who should perish in
the sunlight.
By this point, Paul has reunited with Mildred
who's been reborn after being killed by the
Angel,
and he confesses that his real reason for
bringing the Angel to the island was selfish
as he wanted a second chance at life with
Mildred and their daughter Sarah.
Millie understands but counters that his wish
goes against the natural order of things.
We lived our lives.
She grew up and we faded away, and that's
how it's supposed to work.
The cost of his choice is stark as not only
have the vampire mob run riot over the island,
but when Paul finds his daughter in the church
about to burn it down, she's suddenly shot
by Sturge.
Paul tries to bring her back with his blood
before she dies but she spits it out rejecting
the cursed resurrection that would come with
it.
Paul fully understands the horror of the unnatural
force he unleashed and with Millie burns down
the church.
The rec centre goes up in flames next thanks
to Sherriff Hassan and Erin who've doused
it with petrol and, significantly, it's Ali
who sets it alight,
as like Ed and Annie Flynn and some of the
others who turned into vampires, he's able
to resist the urges that come with it and
he does what he can to stop the ghoulish enterprise
even if it means his own death.
Erin in the meantime is attacked by the Angel,
but as it feeds on her she steadily slices
the creature's wings tearing large holes into
them so it can no longer fly properly,
with the hope that it won't be able to reach
the mainland 30 miles away before sunrise.
This moment was foreshadowed during her talk
with Riley about how, when Erin was a child,
her mother wanted to clip the wings of a pair
of pet doves so they wouldn't fly away.
She said,
"Everyone gets their wings clipped at some
point."
With the Rec centre burning, everyone apart
from Bev Keane accepts the fate that awaits
them, and Sturge owns up to the horrors he's
participated in and asks for forgiveness.
Will you forgive me, kid?
I'll forgive you.
Paul asks Millie for forgiveness and tosses
his priest's collar away;
and, as the remaining islanders await the
dawn, they sing the hymn "Nearer, My God,
to Thee", a song often associated with funerals
and which some have said was played on The
Titanic as it sunk.
Hassan and Ali also pray on the beach until
Hassan's overcome by his wounds and his son
burns up.
Bev Keane refuses to give in right to the
bitter end as she tries to dig a shelter in
the sand before going up in flames like everyone
else.
It's ironic that her second and final death
is burning to a crisp given how she decided
to burn down the island and what she quoted
from the book of Revelation about how true
sinners would die:
"As for the cowardly..
..and all of the liars, their place will be
in the lake that burns..
..which is the second death."
Bev, of course, was a huge hypocrite and coward;
notice how at the Easter Vigil she didn't
drink the poison herself and hid in the back
of the building as the others became vampires.
Unlike the rest of the islanders who find
solace together in their final moments, she's
unable to accept responsibility for what's
to come and dies screaming in anger.
The only two people left alive by the end
are Leeza and Warren, Riley's younger brother.
They escaped the massacre at the church without
dying and being resurrected as vampires, so
they're able to survive the sunrise.
The very last words of the finale are Leeza
saying she can no longer feel her legs, meaning
the healing effect of the Angel blood has
worn off and she's paralyzed again.
Now, initially I assumed this implied the
Angel had died in the sunrise;
however, in an interview with The Wrap, the
show's creator Mike Flanagan has said that's
not exactly the case, although he seems to
acknowledge that it might be a valid interpretation
of the ending.
Flanagan said the reason Leeza was becoming
paralysed again was because:
the "concentration in her blood had begun
to tip back.."
and that they "didn't want it to confirm about
The Angel, in […] that you can never kill
fanaticism, it'll always kind of come back."
What Flanagan is referring to about the concentration
in Leeza's blood tipping back is the scientific
explanation that the island's doctor, Sarah
Gunning, came up with for what was going on
with the blood tests she carried out.
Sarah discovered that Erin and her mother's
blood only had relatively small amounts of
an active substance which she saw burn up
whenever it was exposed to sunlight.
And she hypothesised that if the amounts of
this substance were small enough in a person's
body and they stopped receiving any more of
it, they would eventually excrete it from
their system.
I think when we ingest poison, alcohol, whatever,
before a certain point, if we stop taking
it in, maybe our body can push it back out.
This appears to be what happened with Leeza
as now that she's gone some time without communion,
the effects of the Angel blood seem to be
wearing off hence the return of her paralysis.
By the way, if you want to know why Father
Paul was able to wander around in the daylight
for the first two episodes without burning
up, it's because he never actually died in
the cave.
The Angel gave him blood to heal his wounds
while he was still alive, and because he hadn't
died at that point and been reborn, he was
able to move around in the daylight.
According to Flanagan, this was part of the
Angel's plan so that Paul could help the creature
get out of the cave.
Flanagan also said that the reason for Paul's
death in the third episode was because he'd
"taken in too much of the blood, [and it hit]
that critical mass that Sarah talks about".
What I think Flanagan's referring to is Sarah's
explanation that the Angel's blood is like
a virus, a parasite or a poison of sorts and
that if it accumulates too much it can kill
you.
As a Catholic priest, Paul would be obliged
to consume all the leftover communion wine
from every Mass, so he'd likely be drinking
more of it than anyone else.
Of course, Flanagan's suggestion that the
Angel isn't necessarily dead leaves the potential
for a follow-up second season if we assume
that it did reach the mainland and find cover
before the dawn.
As bad as those cuts were, the Angel does
have the power of self-healing, so although
it's a horrifying thought, it does leave the
opportunity to pick up this story again should
Flanagan want to.
I want to thank the sponsor of this video
NordVPN, an awesome VPN service that keeps
our online work and activity private and secure.
You might not know but many internet service
providers keep a record of all your online
activity and can even sell your data to third
parties.
And in some countries, a wide range of institutions
can also access your internet records without
a warrant to snoop on your browsing habits.
An easy way to stop this is by using a virtual
private network whenever you're online.
A VPN encrypts your connection and makes your
browsing history, emails you send and private
messages unreadable to your ISP.
But using a free VPN can slow your browsing
down to such a snail's pace that it feels
the life's being sucked out of you, much like
the inhabitants of Crockett Island.
Our experience with Nord at Flicks And The
City though has been great, and we've always
been able to get blisteringly fast download
and upload speeds with the service.
Nord has zero bandwidth throttling plus a
no-log policy so it doesn't record or retain
details of your online activity when you're
connected to its service.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers a huge discount on a two-year
plan plus four months free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or go to the
link in the video description to grab the
offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
So, what did you think of Midnight Mass and
how it ended?
And do you think it's possible that the Angel
survived?
Leave your thoughts and theories in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up and
a share are hugely appreciated.
And if you're a Mike Flanagan fan, tap left
to check out all the easter eggs and hidden
ghosts in The Haunting of Bly Manor or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!